most people in their early 20s greatest
mistake is not understanding how young
they are having it figured out by 25 27
30 is ridiculous you haven't even
started do not listen to your parents or
society that you have to have it figured
out it's just not true most of your
parents have not had it figured out ever
let alone at 2223 take a breath most of
you are stressed about getting a job and
then you're going to have a job in six
months and you're not even gonna like it
this doesn't mean be lazy and chill on
the couch have ambition and conviction
but have patience and humility people's
relationship with time is their greatest
vulnerability live for you be high risk
now because it's actually practical